car prices used car prices are now
growing at a faster rate than bitcoin
market researcher jim bianco warns it's
called bubblicious who was trying to buy
a car a used car what was it what'd you
say you said a uh honda hrv uh somebody
in the office can buy a honda hrv new
for 23 000 i believe and they were
trying to buy a used one it was like 30
grand that's just freaking crazy to me
you know we were asking i asked david
what is a used car what does a used car
have that a brand new car doesn't have
he said it's got miles on it it's got
miles on it that's the difference
anyways research right yeah in-depth
research so bitcoin is up five percent
of over the last four months based on
thursday's stock market closed the smp
is up 26
so far this year but apparently these
used car prices uh they've gone up 49
call it 50
so instead of buying bitcoin buy a bunch
of used cars and sit in the backyard and
wait for it to go up that's pretty much
the strategy is that what you're doing
david that's exactly what i'm doing
that's why i was away for a week i was
wondering why the other day i pulled
into work i'm like there's not a single
parking spot up here what the hell is
david doing my like 30 cars here
do you have any thoughts on that right
now because i'm looking at cars right
now and i actually got to give a shout
out to my buddy joey b up in pittsburgh
right now who actually works for an auto
dealer
and i and look number one a car is not
an investment so this is this this
article by cnbc
is is actually just looking for
headlines looking for clicks this you
can park sponsored by uber exactly
um look there's a couple things that are
driving the prices up of cars number one
the global supply chain supply and
demand there's not they're not making
enough cars because not a lot of people
are working
and
everyone needs a car right now right
you all hear what you hear about the
chip shortages
right you hear about um
the the the big thing if you remember
this this is my point here and i asked
dude why
why are car prices going up somewhere
this guy who specializes in cars
actually might be a great interview for
valuetainment
um
they specialize in cars
and he says you remember at the
beginning of the pandemic when hertz and
alamo
and all the car companies sold hundreds
of thousands of cars because nobody was
driving they got rid of their cars they
got rid of their supply and then all of
a sudden demand has shot up so what's
happening now is these
uh rental car companies are basically
saying we need cars we've sold all our
cars we need cars so there's a there's
an auction for cars that you need to be
a dealer to go and these
uh
um car rental companies are going and
paying above
asking price because they need the
flipping cars and they're saying okay
cool that's 10 grand we'll give you 12
grand that's 15 grand we'll give you 20
grand because they need the inventory
and it's driving the price up it's
driving the price up and they're driving
the price up but supply and demand i i
say valuetainers come together start a
golf on me
raise enough money and buy you a i don't
know used 1979 honda accord
okay
and with low profile wheels yeah a
decent system sound system pioneer yeah
pioneer base in the trunk and park it
outside and license plate says
a sauce
s dollar sign sauce tks dollar sign you
just have to make sure you don't wreck
it by the way you can actually buy a
honda accord 1979 for less than a
thousand dollars yeah legit
religious it's considered classic anyway
maybe our friend adriana will donate a
thousand bucks we'll buy a car and then
i'll be less divisive and i'll just
drive around check this out
mr clean bald guy that's his name i wish
he had a different name but that's your
name you you made that your account name
yeah he says i'm a fraud analyst for
experian and i specifically deal with
finance of used cars as soon as the
chips come in all of these people who
just bought are going underwater
immediately 10 or 40 percent explain
that again so what he's trying to say is
the moment the chips come in yeah all
these used prices are going to go back
to the prices they weren't going to drop
50 percent the cars the cars that's what
he's saying so the whole article is
basically calling bubblicious is the car
yeah it's a bunch it's a bubble yeah
that's what he's saying your car that
that should be worth 10 that you paid
15.20 for is going to go down so david
buying all these used cars in a parking
lot he's about to lose a ton of money
but i got to flip them like now
why we gotta wrap this up
anyways question is when are these chips
coming in that's the question why don't
you call xingping ask him so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]